das peinlich so war wir mussten dann
einfach einen anderen lehrer holen der
sich damit auskennen weißt du der kam in
die klasse alle kinder sitzt du weißt du
so einen meter groß kommt also oft sind
fette leinwand weil das war ja überblick
über meine leute was ganz willkommen
beim neuen video ich habe heute mal
wieder den harwich dabei und zu haben
wir uns gedacht wir geben euch mal so
ein bisschen die möglichkeit auch mal so
richtig dabei zu sein und so richtig
mitzufiebern und zu raten und zwar haben
wir beide uns richtig krasse story jetzt
der eine hat sich die ausgedacht und bei
dem anderen stimmt die wirklich also
eine story israel und die anderes nur
ausgedacht so eine story früh genauso
war dass wir zählen jetzt gleich
hintereinander und ihr müsst dann in die
kommentare schreiben
welche story list welche reels und am
ende gibt's was zu gewinnen
aber damit eure in die kommentare
schreiben reinigt ganz umsonst haben uns
gedacht locken wir euch auch ein
bisschen mit seinem richtig fetten preis
vielleicht was kriegt der gewinner das
kommt so was richtig heftiges zugewinn
leute uns was soll das jetzt zeigen hier
die restlichen auf jeden fall kommt von
mir weil so ein workshop on leider gibt
es an pullis und so habe ich ganz viele
leute nachgefragt wird unter euch jetzt
auch leute geben die sagen öl von dem
freilich wenig so scheiße und haben aber
wiederum andere die rein denke als
200.000 abonnenten und will mir schon so
ein scheiß fully andré weiss heute also
unter den ganzen kommentare schreibern
den wert 1 aus der halle richtig gelegen
hat die auflösung kommt bei 10.000 like
oder 10.000 sammelt 20 index nicht mehr
ich das schaffe ja okay die auflösung
kommt dabei 12.000 like sobald es
erreicht ist suche ich mir ein paar
leute aus zwei drei leute ich will leben
sie dürfen sich dann auf jeden fall aus
diesem shop was aussuchen
er kommt in zwei oder drei wochen
anleihen keine ahnung und ja wir wollen
nicht langsam anfangen direkt mal an
schnick schnack schnuck schnick schnack
schnuck schnick schnack schnuck leute
fangen an mit der story und so leute als
ich 14 15 jahre alt war ging ich von der
schule nach hause
in seinem aufsatz zu er ging von der
schule nach hause ging ich nach hause
leute und habe mich wie immer aufs essen
gefreut und dann komme ich zu hause an
und sehe meine älteren meine geschwister
auch einfach niemand ist zu hause und da
muss ich mir das essen halt selber
machen und mein lieblingsessen des
pommes das geht halt einfach richtig
sich ein paar kartoffeln pommes und die
da rein und da warte ich als 10 15 uhr
sind wir fertig landtag kommt während
der zeit gehe ich hoch und zog ein
bisschen the place und dabei sonst
zocken vertieft leute und hören und
knistern gehe die treppe runter und
alles voller rauch ehrlich alles aber
voller rauch und ich denke mir so margot
was soll ich machen ich war unterm
strich heraus vor die haustüren genau
nehmen unsere haustür war ein
kindergarten und ich reise hilfe keiner
beachtet mich kommt so machen fahrrad
hält an und sagt oh mein gott schon die
feuerwehr gerufen
nein wir stehen voll nicht drauf
gekommen und ruft er und ich denke mir
so ich musste schnell ins haus muss ich
etwas vergessen und damit nehmen sie
auch mein gott bestimmt sein kleiner
bruder oder kleine schwester wenn man
hält mich fest ich kann so ins haus rein
leute ohne scheiß ich komme mit einer
playstation raus so rausgerannt mal
gucken mich so richtig fett zu berlin
ecke so richtig unter dem schock der
mission
bestimmt ist das ernst ich rennens noch
mal rein alles anbrennen obwohl den
plötzlichen daraus kann man dort stehen
ja heute was irgendwie hat es für das
gros sagen glaubt ihr dass instruiert
oder glaubt ihr das ist fällt schreibt
es in die kommentare aber jetzt kommt
mir zu weihnachten und daran erinnere
ich mich echt als wäre es erst gestern
gewesen
aber ich war schon vor 6 jahren auf
jeden fall war ich deine sechsten klasse
und wir hatten halt so irgendwie pc
unterricht bei einem lehrer der keine
ahnung davon hat wisst ihr da wurden wir
gerade sollen das internet herangeführt
und so was man alles machen kann blabla
nicht nur fröhlich wenn meine tochter
wurde mir so ans internet herangeführt
und haben also ein paar dinge
ausprobiert aber wir können uns doch
schon so ein bisschen aus weißt du
und dann haben wir halt so referate
gemacht und dann mussten muss sich halt
vorher vorstellen ich habe das alles so
irgendwie keine ahnung powerpoint oder
so gab es auch schon muss sich also ein
bisschen erzählen dazu dann meinte sie
kollege was heißt kollegen damals den
freuen zu auf jeden fall weiter dazu mir
wenn ihr vorne seid also wir waren halt
so eine ganze gruppe geht man auf google
hemmer so nach dem motto 'wenn du hast
gehst du auf google hämmern weiß was es
ist
ich wusste gar nicht was das ist ich
dachte ja normal habe ich habe auf jeden
fall weiteren vorne
ich gehe auf diese seite so so google
hemmer haldimann schreibt ich hoffe dass
meine lehrerin so die wusste selber
nicht mal wie man das internet öffnet
oder sonstwas nah aber keine ahnung
warum die warum solche lehrerin dann in
pcs rauen reingelassen wir hatten
wisst ihr und dann ging diese seite auf
und ihr müsst euch vorstellen weiß gar
nicht wie ich das jetzt sagen da sind
auf jeden fall so zwei männer und die
sind halb nackt bei einem eines halt
vorne weist und der andere liegt halt
runter und das ist also eine dauer
streifen mit so richtig schlüssige musik
weißt du
und das geht nicht wecken und die
treiben haben dann halt spaß miteinander
und das beste stück von dem vorderen
meines schwingkreisel die konzerne und
ich dachte mir so etwas jetzt ist das
mache ich jetzt meinen lehrer guckt so
die vase man sah so dass die sauber ist
und so das ding ja wir kannten uns alle
wohlauf und das ging nicht weg wir sind
kann ich auf die idee gekommen den pc
einfach mal auszumachen oder so nicht
das peinlich so war wir mussten dann
einfach einen anderen lehrer holen der
sich damit auskennt weißt du der kam in
die klasse alle kinder sitzt also weiß
wieso so für einen meter groß kunden
also oft sind fette leinwand weil das
war über bibi manne und gucken da dieses
schwulen porno
was ist hier los das war auf jeden fall
das peinlichste was mut ohne scheiß das
war mit abstand das peinlichste was wir
in einem ganzen leben passiert ist
treibt einfach jetzt in die kommentare
welches sorry ich kann das gar nicht aus
springt auf jeden fall wenn ihr denkt
seine story war ihm dann schreibt sowie
nummer eins oder erste story und wenn
ihr denkt meine war ihr dann schreibt
zweite story oder alex sowieso keine
ahnung
und ja gewinner können was gewinnen
gewundert kammerspielen der link zu
seinem channels und in der video
beschreibung checkte smarter kam auch
ebenen video glaube ich genau mit den
jungen mann hier wieder ansatz hat euch
gefallen wenn ihr merkt ob solche real
live videos dann könnte ich ja auch noch
in die kommentare schreiben oder so und
drei leute